[Music]
hi everyone you might not recognize
where I'm sitting right now but this is
our new living room it's almost complete
not yet there's still a few things we
gotta fill in here we moved out the
other couch that we had here and then we
moved out the dining table Thanks
we have so much space now for activities
[Music]
like what is that that's your dancing
[Music]
but yeah so we ended up moving
everything out because our dining table
and our coffee table is supposed to be
coming in any day now we just don't know
when exactly but good news is Ivan's bed
is coming today finally finally it's
coming any minute now they should be
arriving we have these trays that belong
upstairs we have them down here because
it's been our dining table for the past
couple days since we don't have our
dining table anymore we moved it out to
the garage but look how gorgeous this
living room looks already the plans are
these two guitars here we're gonna hang
them on that wall and then we're gonna
get a rug here and then put the coffee
table and then right here another rug
and then our dining table with the two
benches and then two chairs on the end
do you like all this extra space
[Music]
he puts his head down how cute it's so
sweet
and look at my over there she's like huh
you don't do that with me and then the
bidets came in and also this little
thingy here came in thank you to mama
and papa chan they gave us new bidets
slurs of the day here and where else
smarter bets my bathroom in your room
yeah in your bathroom now and then it's
cool cuz I only have the room out right
here so it's like right in front we will
be getting wallpaper I already ordered
the wallpaper so I'm excited for that
and then thank you guys I read your
comments and you're saying how dangerous
it is to not have these thingies down
here we'll figure that out but as of now
it has a not fallen thank goodness
having fall out of breath on my blog
what are you doing you got a scar yeah I
see it I don't so pretty bad actually my
goodness
well that was recent right oh my gosh
why do you put that paper by your face
it says you look at you guys oh yeah we
move their food and water over here too
by the way water machine the fountain
it's sitting right there because I have
not decalcified it yet but that's
another project I got to do oh yeah and
then look at our backyard see we had
these these little tile thingies and our
balcony from the old place and then we
set up this thingy here because we like
the view the mountain over there so why
are you peeling potatoes doing some
quarantine cooking we're gonna make a
whole bunch of mash those
a whole bunch of try dude yeah bro my
favorite yeah we have a lot of food in
the fridge right it's already cooked but
I also just need to cook all the other
stuff because it's gonna yeah look at it
oh my goodness
can we eat that yeah I have to know
about it I didn't know they haven't ever
seen my potatoes get this far into like
this process whatever it's probably
nothing yeah but apparently you just cut
it off and it's so good by the potato
just soften a little bit
oh I think it's time we just we we got
to make potatoes because there's three
more in that name at all I don't know
maybe uh uh yeah here the rest well
these don't have sprouts yeah I took all
the problems we're gonna we're gonna die
you'd be sprouting potatoes we're gonna
die man oh my goodness that is out the
dark now I was thinking Oh actually
actually eat these first or else this is
gonna be covered in sprouts yeah you're
right right yeah these still got time
yeah they're still pretty good
whoa look at this onion though is this I
think we should throw this one away
oh yeah I was cooking with onions the
other days too and they had that and I
just cut it off oh okay yeah you're
right the other half looks pretty good
avocados we have thanks to and Christina
I actually peeled and mashed three
avocados today so I made more of my guac
there's a whole bunch of it without look
where they go with this tribe - OH
district
California staple there we go and the
way they eat is with like Mexicali and
breathe alright so while you do that I
want to show them the changes upstairs
though very few changes but can I just
point out that every time I walk up
these stairs I just feel so freakin
happy like I love it doors are so fun
and then little bit look it's like
happiness happiness and then more
happiness look at this so pretty so we
ended up hanging that up and then we
brought the carpet or the rug I don't
know if I showed you guys this yet but I
just love this like so pretty and then I
think can I show them your room yeah
okay and then look at Isaac's bedroom so
he fixed it up today
I helped him hang that up and then we
brought the tree in here just so much
more livelier he's getting his frame
finally and then that desk is on order
so this is his room I was actually
thinking about doing some sort of
wallpaper on this wall because I think
it would just like make it look more
vibrant and more bright more well
designed but then Isaac was like yeah we
don't need to do it so I'm like all
right it's me a lot of work but I did
buy wallpaper for the laundry room it's
gonna be like a floral yellow like green
yellow oh yeah look at Isaac's the day
he got a bidet now - Thank You papa che
and him on the chin
it's kind of cool it has like a
nightlight in there this has been most
of Isaac's days just sitting here and
playing video games
can ask you a question yeah are you
gonna die if I bother you for a second
no you wanna pawn this so I can't follow
oh so you will die oh yeah I could I
could concentrate on your question okay
multitask
how has quarantine life been for you
awesome
the dream I'm living the life I get to
sleep in I could stay up watch the
office as many times as I want mm-hmm
and play video games for as long as they
want and tiny D I need to show
responsibility to keep on playing more
it's a win-win so what do you mean show
responsibility like keep on do my
homework yeah and my tour is true so
it's pretty good kudos to myself you
could tell us yourself that's sure it's
all pretty good but aren't you you've
expressed how you do miss your friends
and stuff huh I feel like I should have
said a proper goodbye
I know that's the one thing empty with
that saying a proper goodbye cuz I'm not
gonna see him anymore true since we
moved cities you didn't get to say
goodbye to your friends I know I thought
Oh be back next week true cuz you're
still had like what two more months left
to school yeah two or three two and a
half or something soon enough yeah in
exchange for seeing all my friends
you're not saying the proper goodbye
I get to live the life yeah but I did
feel empty without saying that proper
goodbye
I know well the good thing is you have
their contact you can be texting them
and facetiming them only on my two best
friends numbers true you know what I
like about the switch mmm it tells you
how many hours you've played on the game
but the Xbox it doesn't show you like
for this game that I'm playing you
already it would say like that was oh
really
you've been playing a thousand hours of
this what game is this phantom force oh
it looks like Call of Duty kind
first-person shooter I walk away baby
but I can't
yeah it's rater than buddy so some
upgrades or not upgrades but updates in
the bedroom we brought the office chair
from downstairs
we hung some stuff up here hung that up
hung that up
we have some stuff here I love this
photo
Isaac was walking me down the aisle so
cute we hung this up
the painting that Casey and I painted
together but I couldn't get it really
straight so don't start it too long or
else is gonna start looking crooked oh
and then I decided to put my stool there
at the end of the the closet and I just
I don't know just that one little piece
there it just made me love this closet
even more it's been really fun putting
the Tufts together just all these little
projects everywhere and it kind of got
obsessed with wallpapers after doing
this so I ordered a wallpaper for the
master bathroom and then the laundry
room and then this bathroom so those
projects are gonna be fun once they are
complete how's this coming along good
I'm trimming the fat cap because I don't
want to have such a fatty brisket I wish
this is a brisket this is the attractive
what happened a fat is flavor
I hear the world is gaining weight I
really do I am trying nothing can you
wait myself you know why I've actually
heaven has been working out as much as I
thought I would the first like a week of
quarantine I was working out like crazy
and then I just dropped off I was like
oh you know what else to do other than
to eat some junk food and that is so
true up in the whole thing because when
your mom was here remember we did yoga
together and another is a ton of space
to do yoga and I ordered another yoga
mat for you to do yoga with me and we
still haven't done it
humans will be humans in the fact that
we're always amazing human experience
yeah we're always gonna be really
gung-ho and excited about something in
the beginning of it and then once it
gets old it we just kind of like
true are you over this time keeping my
over X yes and no yes because it is just
getting really boring everyday when it
feels like the same day is happening
every day but then no when something new
arrives that it's a new project to do
for our house and then I get really
excited because I'm like oh we get to do
this I'm so glad we have the time to do
this oh yeah true and otherwise would be
so imparted with like JK stuff or like
other work stuff that we have that's a
lot of fat I keep seeing you trim it I'm
like that looks like it's chicken yeah
well it's gonna render when you cook it
so we're not actually eating all this
fat guys do you think this they call it
a fat cap mm-hmm so we're 1/5 of meat
has all the fat and the other side has
no effect it will render and it that's
what keeps it juicy but it was just so
much of it I was like oh yeah so I'm
back cut too much here yeah there's some
bald spots boom but yeah I'm trying to
keep a thin layer of it look at all the
sex I don't think that's a lot can you
make your own oil out of that yeah like
lard yeah you make oh that's how they
make lard my my culture uses a lot of
lard yes and it never knew where where
it really came from I knew it was fat
but like I don't know and they're really
not about it or oh is this pork is beef
oh it's beef how come they don't make
beef fat beef lard I'm pretty sure they
do the common one so you doing
[Music]
to season the tri-tip what I like to do
is put some Lowery's on it it's
all-purpose and it tastes really really
good and Tiffany's like really really
really really like Lowery's on just
about everything so actually start off
with the pepper then the Lowrey stands
the combination of garlic chili powder
and cumin oh and some red pepper flakes
just and a little bit of spice to it
[Music]
all right so now we are about to cook
the tri-tip
and the first thing was tri-tip is you
want to pan fry it you want to hear both
sides of the tri-tip before putting it
into the oven because we're going to
finish it in the oven you want to cook
the fat side down first and sizzle that
and create the outer shell for the meat
so that all the juices on the inside can
stay moist and can circulate throughout
the entire piece of tri-tip what I'm
using now is a wok to sear the the
tri-tip first normally what you want to
do is go outside and use your trusty
trusty weber grill to sear the outside
and then actually we were just i would
just normally cook the tribe to the
outside sear it and then cook it in
direct heat so you bake you're basically
baking it but since we move i have also
thrown out all my grills because the HOA
here does not want us to have charcoal
grills so after the whole quarantine
thing is done I'm thinking about buying
a an electric grill or a electric smoker
with the pellets and all so never have
to deal with charcoal ever again it's
much cleaner it's gonna be pretty
awesome actually I'm actually looking
forward to the day where I can actually
cook outside again in the time being we
will make do with this wok and we're
going to sear it here and then in the
oven it goes
I've already got this preheated at 400
degrees
[Music]
burned it a little bit a little bit I
was a dicing up some garlic and I was
like Oh totally forgot about the meat
once you're done here in here we're
gonna put it back into the pit of the
baking pan that we had I'm gonna throw
it into the oven for about like 25
minutes and general rule of thumb is for
every pound of tri-tip you bake for like
10 to 15 minutes
[Music]
all right and another general rule of
thumb is to have the fat cap facing up
once you put it into the oven so that
the fat cap can render and it drips into
the rest of me making the meat super
tender and juicy
[Music]
I like to add a little bit of garlic in
there about a clove or two depending I
don't know it really depends upon
whether or not I like to chop up more
garlic than not and then I added some
milk to splash a bit salt pepper and a
secret ingredient is sour
this is a big fan of sour cream on a big
in a circle but one person is coming
ahead is not his Isaac he hates sour
cream by itself
he doesn't realize him about just about
everything and that's it mashed potatoes
is done we're gonna let it rest right
here almost like a foil on it so we can
create a caboose Chur thing I can't
English we're gonna let it sit and let
it reduce tribute all the juices and let
it flow throughout the piece I'm gonna
put some foil on top of this so it'll
trap the moisture and we'll have some
really really really juicy medium to
medium-rare tri-tip in just a second I'm
about to saute some Brussels sprouts and
in this wok that I was using to sear the
tri-tip I have a lot of crack-tip juices
and the seasonings from the tri-tip
I'm unutilized that with this so I
recycle all this goodness right here
Oh yummy so the food's done did you like
all my assistants yes it was very
helpful was it yep that moral support
yes
standing right here yes yes oh that
looks really yummy oh you did yeah when
it don't bit I want it to be a little
more rare it's not like it rare doubt
you ever get rare doubt buy your steak
no sometimes I'm like I'm staring at on
my pants really red no sometimes it's
like to read but I actually really like
medium rare because I grew up Mexican
which means we fully fully fully cook
our meat and I never knew the joys of
medium rare until I met you and I'm like
oh my goodness this is why I grew up
hating meat because I'm bored
yeah it's like burn up my state I
remember thinking like I would eat the
rice I would eat the beans I would eat
the salad or whatever else is there and
I would always leave the meat for the
very very last thing and a lot of the
times I wouldn't even eat the meat
because I just hate it
how much chewing a head to do I'm like
this is this like way too chewy like why
is this meat always so dry in two weeks
that's why you like Mac okay oh really
fluffy
ever since meeting you though my hubby
you introduced me to delicious
medium-rare meats and everything here at
learn to enjoy tougher makes oh if I'm
literally thing I hate it and taco you
know that really your it looks delicious
just missing some gravy you know that
volcano I'm miss doing that volcano the
volcano front of the school lunches I
don't know you don't like about never
got mashed potatoes at school and then
they make this and then it go you know
take this guy and not have like a thing
of gravy and ago Oh smash and doing it
and they create a whole and they drop
the rest it's like a crater the crater
yeah
it's like losing outside the volcano
would be like all like really pointing
you know yeah
thank know it to me now yeah
but I never got that at school dancy
good oh yeah microwaved teriyaki chicken
with some rice and some cabbage I guess
it's kind of dank oh my goodness I put
my finger under here yeah oh my gosh
we're gonna clean this yeah the one
thing Oh greasy the one thing I don't
like about having this whole microwave
up above the stove is that the microwave
gets decimated by grease stains yeah
it's so true
cook once it's actually not that bad
right now but sometimes it's like
completely covered with grease and then
these cabinets are getting tore up just
I mean I wash my hands linner
has been served lunch and dinner like
the meal between lunch in there I got 3
a.m. or something
between dinner and breakfast but the
other way by not between breakfast and
dinner exact time did you do it on
purpose no oh that's funny you are my
child
ok let's see I want to taste it oh man
do the mashed potatoes are bombs
Oh try it try it try it
wow it's delicious huh sour cream by
itself
he doesn't realize how came about just
about everything good Popham greens
never get to shine by everyone always
you're like oh the the meat the mistake
the chicken gets a lot of attention and
then the car the matte container with
the pasta the rice or whatever the
noodles is a lot of tension but no one
goes the vegetables yes amazing because
they're vegetables and like
stereotypically veggies are yucky or
vegetables are easy to make
and there's nothing you can do to spice
it up I mean mucus seasoned vegetables
yeah but it's not great job with the
Brussels sprouts they're delicious
they're like the creme de la creme the
Brussels pressed rose arrow all right
let's play some I Love Lucy you ready
mmm - what all right guys after we ate
there was a knock at the door and
finally the package that we have been
waiting for had finally arrived
that means the bedframe saga is complete
and Isaac now has a finished room oh
yeah nice parkour parkour
you're just missing your desk and that's
it boy now you're all done and then look
this bed has these drawers so you got
extra storage in here maybe put other
stuff that's easy to access true under
the bed on this side nice high five I
feel good I feel like I'm gonna have a
good night's sleep
[Music]